voir les BIXI partiront pour un
usage en novembre. Il y aura un
projet pilote cette année.
- Il fallait une tempête précoce
à l'automne pour avoir une image
de BIXI sous la neige.
sesesesera, dès l'hiver prochai,
beaucoup plus fréquent de voir
ces vélos en libre-service
dans les rues enneigées
de la métropole. BIXI et la
Ville ont profité du lancement
de la saison pour l'annoncer.
SOPHIE MAUZEROLLE, responsable
transport, mobilité Ville Mtl
- Un projet pilote de vélos BIXI
à l'année sur le territoire
de Montréal.
- Sur les 10 000 vélos
disponibles pendant la saison
régulière, 1500 resteront
à la disposition des Montréalais
entre le 15 novembre
et le 15 avrnsnsnsns sept
arrondissements.
BIXI s'occupera du déneigement
des stations, qui ne seront
ni sur les trottoirs ni
sur lapupupupublique. Et il va
falloir mieux équiper les vélos.
ALEXANDRE TAILLEFER, président
conseil d'administration, BIXI
- Donc, on introduit des pneus
crampons, qui vont être beaucoup
plus solides et qui vont
permettre un freinage plus
rapide dans des conditions
glissantes.
- Je trouve ça difficile aussi
l'hiver d'avoir un vélo adéquat
pour se promener en ville,
donc si BIXI peut rendre ça
disponible à tout le monde,
c'est formidable.
- Très bonne nouvelle pour qu
on fait un aller simple et qu'on
prend le métro et l'autobus
pour revenir, très bonne idée.
- Y aura-t-il beaucoup d'adeptes
pour tenter l'expérience
hivernale? Les données récentes
semblent montrer un potentiel.
JEAN-FRANÇOIS RHEAULT,
pdg, Vélo Québec- Quand on rega,
là, de comptage sur les pistes
cyclables, au mois de janvier
et février, il y a eu 22 jours
où il y a eu plus de 1000
passouououououour sur
le REV Saint-Denis.
- Et Montréal se félicite
de cette nouvelle innovation
de BIXI, l'année de ses 15 ans
et alors que son système est
implane e e e e e quarantaine
de grandes villes dans le monde.
VALÉRIE PLANTE
mairesse de Montréal
- C'est un des fleurons de
Montréal. Vous savez, j'étais
au Mexique il n'y a pas
si longtemps, quand on va
à New York, on voit les BIXI
de Montréal, qui ont d'autres
noms, un peu partout, donc
c'est un modèle vraiment,
dont on est fiers.
- Autre nouveauté :
la possibilité de débloquer
un vélo directement, grâce
à un code QR. Quant
elle annonce aujourd'hui faire
une plus grande place aux
cyclistes dans les métros.
Ce sera possible d'y embarquers,
même aux heures de pointe.
Ici Mathieu Prost,